There is no way we can throw away something
as important as a dimension without there
being some consequences and there are some
quite significant consequences, but we tend
not to think about them.
If I look at this scene of parallel railway
lines, they clearly appear to converge and
we expect that. Looking at this scene we know
that they are parallel lines and this comes
from our everyday experience with what a three dimensional world looks like, but it’s kind of surprising
that things that are parallel in the world
appear to us to be converging and we don’t
give it any thought at all. It is unsurprising
to us.
Here is another example, looking up at a bunch
of trees and they appear to be converging
even though these trees are all parallel to
one another, emerging vertically from the
ground plain.
Here is another example of the ferris wheel
and we know that the ferris wheel is round.
Now in this particular image, because I have
looked at it obliquely, it clearly appears
to be elliptical.
So what’s going on here? Well, mathematically
the perspective projection maps lines to lines,
but it doesn't preserve angles. That means that parallel lines in the world will not necessarily
appear to be parallel in an image. There are
cases when there will be, but in general,
parallel lines do not remain parallel after
the projection.
The other shape mapping perceptive projection
does, is it maps conics to conics. So a conic,
short for conic section is the shape that
you get by slicing through a solid cone and
though shapes can be a circle, an ellipse,
a parabola or a hyperbola.